when a celebrity passes away it can feel
like we're losing a friend whether we
watch them on the big screen or let them
into our lives through our TVs the world
seems darker knowing we've had to say
goodbye to a favorite star even though
we can continue and join their work
indefinitely letting their legacies live
on forever here's a fond look back at
some of the stars we've sadly lost in
2017 Bill Paxton veteran actor and
director Bill Paxton who appears an
alien's twister and Titanic died
February 25th following complications
from heart surgery he was 61 beyond
appearing in such movies as weird
science The Terminator and a simple plan
Paxton also starred in the HBO series
Big Love and was nominated for an Emmy
for his role in the TV miniseries
Hatfields and McCoys at the time of his
death he was starring in the CBS reboot
of training day John Hurt legendary
British actor John Hurt who was widely
known for alien the Elephant Man 1984
and Midnight Express died January 25th
after a battle of pancreatic cancer he
was 77 in a career spanning more than
six decades hurt earned two Oscar
nominations and appeared in many notable
television roles perhaps most famously
as the war doctor on Doctor Who in his
later years he played the wand maker
Ollivander in the Harry Potter series
the surrogate father of Hellboy in
Indiana Jones's old friend ox in Indiana
Jones in the kingdom of the Crystal
Skull he was still very active in acting
up until the time of his death
recently appearing in films such as Snow
piercer Mary Tyler Moore television
legend Mary Tyler Moore died January
25th at the age of 80 after suffering
cardiac Ulman area arrest brought on by
pneumonia epoxy and diabetes a
groundbreaking actress she played a
stay-at-home mom on the Dick Van Dyke
Show
then became a feminist icon when she
branched out on her own with the Mary
Tyler Moore Show Moore won six Emmys and
was nominated for an Oscar in 1984
playing the estranged mother of Timothy
Hutton's character in 1980s ordinary
people she was inducted into the
television Hall of Fame in 1986 Don
Rickles one of the most famous and
popular stand-up comedians of all time
Don Rickles died April 6th at his home
in Los Angeles after succumbing to
kidney failure at the age of 90 known
for his abrasive
style of comedy Rickles had a career
that spans six decades a regular at
celebrity roasts in an honorary member
of the Rat Pack he would often take jabs
at audience members with two signature
phrases dummy and hockey puck in 2007 he
won an Emmy for the John Landis directed
documentary mr. warmth the Don Rickles
project but is perhaps best known to
modern audiences as the voice of mr.
Potato Head in the Toy Story movies
[Music]
miguel ferrer a character and voice
actor who appeared in an assortment of
films including Robocop and starred on
the TV series NCIS Los Angeles Miguel
Ferrer died of cancer on January 19th at
the age of 61 Ferrer had recently
reprised his twin peaks' role as FBI
pathologist Albert Rosenfield for
Showtime survival of the cult classic
drama the son of 50 singer Rosemary
Clooney and actor Jose Ferrer he was
also George Clooney's first cousin
Charlie Murphy the older brother of
Eddie Murphy Charlie Murphy became a
household name on Chappelle's Show
sharing stories about his time in Los
Angeles during the height of his
brothers fame in the 1980s Murphy also
appeared in numerous movies including
night at the Museum and Norbit where he
provided the voice of Lloyd the dog in
TV series like are we there yet and
black Jesus he also did voice work for
the animated series The Boondocks in the
video game Grand Theft Auto San Andreas
Charlie Murphy died of leukemia on April
12th he was 57 John heard a lifelong
actor and veteran of both film and
television John Hurt appeared in dozens
of projects from shows like The Sopranos
to acclaimed movies such as awakenings
but he'll always be best known as
Kevin's hapless dad Peter in the home
alone films sadly on July 21st Hurd
passed away unexpectedly at the age of
71 while recovering from back surgery
Chuck Barris prolific TV host and
producer Chuck Barris died of natural
causes on March 21st he was 87 best
known as the producer and host of the
groundbreaking gong show
Ferris also created the dating game and
the newlywed game in his book
confessions of a dangerous mind Ferriss
also claimed to have actually been a CIA
assassin while he was a TV producer in
the 60s and 70s
Sam Rockwell portrayed him in a 2002
film adaptation that was written by
Charlie Kaufman and directed by George
Clooney erin moran the beloved actress
who played Joanie Cunningham on happy
days and Joanie Loves Chachi erin moran
died from complications of cancer on
April 22nd at the age of 56 over the
course of her career moran also appeared
on TV shows from Gunsmoke to Murder She
Wrote
to the Love Boat her last project was
the 2010 film not another b-movie
Christopher Boykin one of the stars of
MTV's Robbin big Christopher big black
Boykin died May 9th from a heart attack
The Bodyguard and best friend of
skateboarder and entrepreneur rob dyrdek
he rose to fame on the reality series
that followed the pair during their
day-to-day lives from 2006 until 2008
Boykin later appeared on several
episodes of the follow-up series Rob
Dyrdek's Fantasy Factory and Dyrdek's
clip show ridiculousness
he also started a clothing line in 2007
Michael parks a veteran character actor
who appeared in more than 100 films and
TV shows Michael parks died May 9th at
the age of 77 best known for working
with directors Quentin Tarantino Robert
Rodriguez and Kevin Smith parks played
Texas Ranger Earl McGraw in Kill Bill
Vol 1 in Esteban Vee heyo in Kill Bill
Vol 2 while Smith said he wrote the
movies red state and tusk specifically
for Parks parks also played
french-canadian drug runner genre know
on the ABC television series Twin Peaks
Richard Hatch one of the stars of both
the original Battlestar Galactica and
the sci-fi remake Richard Hatch died
February 7th from pancreatic cancer at
the age of 71 hatch got his start in
1970 on the soap opera All My Children
before being cast as Captain Apollo on
the cult favorite sci-fi series which
earned him a Golden Globe nomination in
1979 he also appeared on dynasty in
Santa Barbara before playing Tom Zarek
in the reboot of Battlestar Galactica
from 2004 to 2009 he also wrote five
original Battlestar novels and became a
fixture at comic book conventions and
sci-fi events
Martin Landau oscar-winning actor Martin
Landau died July 15th after a short
hospitalization at Ronald Reagan UCLA
Medical Center where he suffered
unexpected complications he was 89
Landau was a cartoonist before he rose
to fame with his portrayal of a henchman
in Alfred Hitchcock's 1959 classic North
by Northwest in the 60s he turned down
the role of Spock on Star Trek and
played rowling hand the man of a million
faces on Mission Impossible for three
seasons he later earned Emmy nominations
for performances on HBO's entourage and
CBS series without a trace
Landau also earned three Oscar
nominations over the course of his
career winning Best Supporting Actor in
1995 for his portrayal of Bela Lugosi in
the film Ed Wood George Romero the
director of the iconic horror classic
Night of the Living Dead George Romero
died July 16th after battling lung
cancer he was 77
Romero made Night of the Living Dead on
a budget of just 114 thousand dollars
and it went on to make 30 million at the
box office the black and white film
about a group of people trapped by a
horde of the undead was integral in
creating the modern zombie genre he
later directed 1978 Dawn of the Dead in
1985 s Day of the Dead as well as genre
films Knight Riders Creepshow and
monkeyshines
chester bennington actor and singer for
the band Linkin Park Chester Bennington
committed suicide by hanging on July
20th at the age of 41
Bennington joined Linkin Park before the
release of the band's debut album Hybrid
Theory in 2000 which went on to become a
massive commercial success paving the
way for six more studio albums he also
fronted the side project dead by Sunrise
and served as the singer of Stone Temple
Pilots after the band parted ways with
original frontman Scott Weiland on the
big screen
Bennington appeared in saw 3d the final
chapter crank and crank high-voltage
judge joseph Wapner star of the reality
series the People's Court Judge Joseph
Wapner died of respiratory failure On
February 26 at the age of 97 a graduate
of USC Law School Wapner served in World
War two and later became a judge at the
Los Angeles Superior Court after
retiring he headlined the groundbreaking
show the People's Court which debuted in
1981 he became something of a
pop-culture eye
during his tenure on the show which
ended in 1993 Wapner received a star on
the Hollywood Walk of Fame in 2009 and
on his 90th birthday he returned to the
People's Court to serve as guest judge
Adam West the man who brought Batman to
life for a generation Adam West died at
the age of 88 On June 9th after a short
battle with leukemia a contract player
for Warner Brothers in film and
television starting in the 50s West rose
to international stardom in 1966 as the
star of the massive hit Batman the show
quickly burnt out however and was
canceled after its third season in 1968
typecast as Batman West struggled to
find other roles but later in life
experienced a great career resurgence as
a highly sought-after voice actor on
animated shows including Family Guy West
was given a star on the Hollywood Walk
of Fame in 2012 Roger Moore on May 23rd
beloved actor Roger Moore who played
James Bond in more movies than any other
star in the long-running franchise died
after a short battle with cancer he was
89 before his time is bond Moore played
the dashing thief Simon Templar on the
TV series the Saint which ran for 118
episodes between 1962 and 1969 in 1972
he replaced Sean Connery as
double-oh-seven
first appearing as the secret agent in
1973 s Live and Let Die then portrayed
bond in six more movies his final being
1985 a view to a kill he was known for
bringing a campy sense of humor to the
series in later years he frequently
played off of his fame in films like
spice world powers Boothe an
emmy-winning actor known for Deadwood
and Sin City powers Boothe died at the
age of 68 of natural causes on May 14th
in 1980 his leading role in the TV movie
Guyana tragedy the story of Jim Jones
brought him an Emmy for lead actor in a
limited series are special that launched
a career that led to dozens of
appearances on shows including Marvel's
agents of shield and 24 as well as
movies such as tombstone Nelson Dellis a
fan favorite is Lafayette on the HBO hit
True Blood Nelson Ellis died from
complications of heart failure caused by
alcohol withdrawal on July 8th he was 39
early in his career he appeared on
numerous TV shows including Veronica
Mars
but he made his breakthrough his
Lafayette the short-order cook at
Merlotte's on Tru Blood in the books the
character didn't survive but because
Ellis was so popular writers for the
show decided to change Lafayette's fate
he also appeared in several films most
notably as Martin Luther King jr. in the
2013 film the butler Stevie Ryan actress
and YouTube celebrity Stevie Ryan died
on July 1st at the age of 33 people
reports that the Los Angeles County
coroner's office ruled the death a
suicide by hanging Ryan rose to fame
with her youtube series little loca
which helped land her a vh1 sketch
series called Stevie TV which ran from
2012 to 2013
she later served as co-host of Brody
Jenner's eseries sex with Brody most
recently she co-hosted mentally chil
which is a podcast about depression
according to its iTunes description ryan
revealed that her grandfather had
recently died in an episode that was
released just two days before her death
Michael Nyquist Swedish actor Michael
Nyquist who starred in the original The
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo movies and
later appeared in John wick died June
27th after a battle with lung cancer
after the success of The Girl with the
Dragon Tattoo and it's sequels nyquist
went to Hollywood and appeared in
blockbusters such as Mission Impossible
Ghost Protocol glenne Headly an Emmy
nominated actress known for dirty rotten
scoundrels in the movie adaptation of
Dick Tracy Glynn Headley died June 8th
at the age of 62 Headley started out as
a stage performer before turning her
focus to television and films she was
nominated for Emmys for her performances
in the 1989 miniseries Lonesome Dove in
the 1996 drama bastard out of Carolina
but she was perhaps best known for
playing a con woman in the comedy dirty
rotten scoundrels in 1988 and Tess
Trueheart in Warren Beatty's live-action
Dick Tracy in 1990 in memoriam sadly we
have lost many more stars in 2017 as
well here is a tribute to some of the
other actors and actresses whose talents
will no longer brighten our days Sam
Shepard Robert Hardy
Glen Campbell Haru Nakajima Joe Bologna
Mike Connors
Neil singleton
clay Adler
jeetu kombucha
heaven Hellmuth dick Gautier
[Music]
franciene York
mic act Ari Emanuel Reba Robert Michael
Morris
[Music]
Peter Salas Molly Peters Barbara Hale
red West John seijin
Lisa spoon our Darlene Cates Elena
Verdugo
Roger Smith
[Music]
you